Nikki Haley fine she's not going to tell
you anything she disagrees with trombone
she's not going to draw any policy
distinction she's only going to talk
about identity fine
what about Tim Scott Tim Scott is a
Republican senator from South Carolina
Tim Scott was also given the opportunity
by Sean Hannity to draw a distinction
between himself and Trump when it comes
to policy Tim Scott has not yet
announced that he's running but the
rumors are that he may well be doing
that
he didn't do it either take a look at
this what are the differences in terms
of
policy positions that's for example you
may have with President Trump
not very many at all I'm so thankful
that we have President Trump in office
frankly the policies that we were able
to pass from 2017 to 2020 were a
Monumental and thankful any criticisms
of the guy you might run against since
you'll have to justify why someone would
vote for you over Trump no his policies
were great really I mean it's very
beautiful beautiful presidency Hannity
asked Tim Scott a second time
any just anything you want to mention
here Tim Might we then find ourselves in
a position where you know maybe we'll
have six seven eight maybe ten maybe 20
Republican candidates on a stage that
mostly agree on what the governing
philosophy and ideology should be for
the country what works in the country
that's what we're going to have then
where are the differences what would the
differences be do you think
that's a great question Sean I would
simply say this what I'm learning on my
faith in America Tour is yes in order to
decide whether to run for president I
guess he's learning during a faith in
America Tour oh my goodness tell my
story as an African-American who was
born into poverty
he's doing the identity politics thing
too oh my God these people they no
identity Politics the two people who are
or might be running against Trump talk
only about their identity when asked
about policy differences and then a
single parent household the strength of
my community my Chick-fil-A Mentor who
happened to be a white guy a citadel
graduate from in South Carolina he
taught me that you no matter where
you're born you can rise beyond your
circumstances if you're willing to
perspire because you're inspired by the
American story leaning into that helped
change my life bringing people together
black folks and white folks not because
of the color of our skin but because we
have one single Focus we believe you
might be noticing there are no policy
distinctions here the goodness of
America I want to share with people why
we should be proud of who we are and at
the same time debunk the lies all right
we're gonna stop this is looking like
the identity politics primary of 2024.
on the Republican side let's imagine Tim
Scott gets in next okay we will have
Trump Nikki Haley and Tim Scott any
policy differences at all that any of
you want to cite anything that Trump did
during his presidency that was bad that
you would have done differently
no I don't know but if you want a
younger minority woman you can go with
Nikki Haley it's Trump's policies with a
younger minority woman there's Haley if
you want the slightly older than Nikki
Haley but still younger than Trump and
black version of trump
then you've got Tim Scott that you can
vote for this is unbelievable and it is
another one of these examples of how the
Wright loves to claim the left is all
about canceling and suppressing Free
Speech actually it seems like it's the
right that that is oh the left is all
about
um you know regulating businesses and
telling them what they can do oh it's
actually the right who wants to tell
Twitter and all these other companies
what to do we I could go down the very
very long long list the the left is
about restricting people's freedoms and
it's the right that wants to determine
what people can do in bedrooms for
example and in this case it's the right
that loves to say the left is constantly
doing identity politics identity
politics identity politics they have two
and soon will have three candidates who
seem only willing to challenge the
former president's
um a candidacy on the basis of identity
on the basis of identity Tim Scott being
asked give us some policy differences it
sound like a going to have a bunch of
people on stage who all agree well
listen you know as I go around the
country as a black man what this is now
what the Republican party has become
identity politics it is madness but you
know what
if their voters don't care about policy
maybe this is the smart thing just have
them pick based on identity do you want
the uh indian-american female version of
trump or do you want the black American
male version of trump what what is it
you want because on policy they're not
talking about it and voters quite
frankly don't seem to care wild and
wacky times I'll have these clips for
you on my YouTube channel find it at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
make sure you're subscribed folks we're
trying to push towards 2 million
subscribers and also be aware of the
David packman show now available in
Spanish for our Spanish speakers
davidpackman.com Spanish
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor sure to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below